so as of course everybody knows the uh
conflict which has been going on between
russia and ukraine
since at least 2014 has
ramped up dramatically has accelerated
has become a full-scale war
and many people have asked me why i
haven't been saying much about it why i
haven't been more vocal on social media
or in my videos to talk about what is
going on in that conflict and so i
thought it would be worth the time to
spend a few minutes to explain
first of all why i haven't been more
vocal and maybe give you a little bit of
a sense of my perception of what is
going on or rather why it is that i'm
being very attentive
and a little quiet at the moment to try
to kind of perceive through the
through the the chaos and through the uh
the barrage of information to get a
sense of what is happening on a symbolic
level
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
so the first thing to say is that the
stories we're hearing that we are seeing
coming from ukraine are rather horrible
i think it's very important to pray for
the people of ukraine and to give to the
co to people that can help in the
humanitarian sphere i myself uh worked
for many years with uh with the
mennonite central community mcc which i
trust and which i know does good work
and so we're going to go through that
through that channel to try to uh to do
what we can to help the people of
ukraine i think that's the first thing
to say
i think a lot of people are distressed
especially orthodox christian that are
distressed and are
feel a little bit overwhelmed by the
situation because what we're seeing in
many cases are orthodox christians or at
least people who identify as orthodox
christians
fighting each other
uh invading each other and so
it is very difficult to to kind of
remain calm and to be objective about
that
that has of course been one of the
reasons why i've been quiet but mostly
i'll be honest with you i tend to not
comment too much on international
politics if you follow me you'll notice
that i will talk
about the things that i understand about
the symbolic pattern that i perceive but
i'm not a political commentator i have
been more vocal in the past few months
because things have been happening in my
own sandbox in my own world that i can
see that i can see through because i can
experience it i can you know i have my
feet on the ground i can get a sense of
what is going on um and because i do not
trust the media i do not trust the media
i stop
trusting the media in 2016 when i saw
them going after
uh jordan peterson who i knew and who i
trusted and i saw that what the media
was saying was so completely out of
whack with what he was and what he was
doing what he was saying that from that
moment on i've become extremely critical
of the media apparatus and i saw the
same thing happen in the u.s election in
2016 as well
and since then i'm not going to start
trusting the media
because
because now it's a different subject
that's not going to happen i simply do
not trust
the media i do not trust what we're
getting from official channels in terms
of information and so because it's very
difficult to see through the propaganda
that is being pushed on all sides it is
very difficult to to pronounce yourself
and to speak everybody is going off
on twitter and on social media
and i feel like it is often
irresponsible because we do not know
what is true of what we are being told
of what is happening over there so i
think that's very important to
understand
that one of the reasons why i'm not
saying much is because
i don't know what's going on and i don't
totally trust what i'm hearing what i'm
seeing and i especially don't trust the
motivations of the people that are
taking extreme positions in this
conflict um
i see
what i could only call
let's say
other political reasons why
people are focusing so much on what is
going on and are taking positions so
strongly you know and especially i have
to be honest especially americans i find
it very difficult to watch americans
posture and be extremely arrogant and
extremely
um you know
to take on this strong position of of we
need to defend
democracy and we need to defend people
that are suffering you know in the wake
of the iraqi war of of libya of what's
still going on in yemen of the bombing
in somalia you know
of syria the horrible syrian war which
was which was in
much part backed some of those rebels
which were backed by the united states
and so i i just find it very difficult
to watch people get up on their high
horse and now start to preach to others
i i just struggle to to deal with that
so i think that that's
another thing that's going on in terms
of why i've been kind of quiet about the
the issues that are happening now
let's say the the third reason
or let's say the
the more symbolic reason why i haven't
been
saying much and why i've been paying
attention and watching is because
there's something which happened in
2014
now when the the um
when the coup happened in 2014 you know
the maiden uh
protest and the ousting of the by force
of the president which was there and the
reins the reinstating of a new president
which was there in 2014
there was a lot of things hap a lot of
suspicious things going on but one of
the strangest things that happened
during that time
is that pope francis
did a ceremony
where with a boy and a girl a young boy
dressed in blue and a young girl dressed
in red you know very very powerful
symbolism
uh stood at his window and
released two doves the boy released one
dove and the girl released another dove
for peace in ukraine
and when that happened
as the the doves were flying away from
the the window
the doves were attacked by two birds
one black bird a kind of crow type bird
attacked one of the doves and another a
a kind of seagull
uh bird
attacked the other dove
and it was very dramatic because here
you had these two
kind of uh scavenger
birds
the these kind of scavenger birds that
were now attacking the two doves as if
the prayer was being interrupted by
something as if the request for peace
was being taken up by these these uh
these scavenger birds these aspects of
these aspects of uh of
heaven are these aspects of what is
above which picks up things you know
which are is the more kind of tyrannical
and even scavenger aspect of heaven you
know the darker aspect of
of of a structure let's say
um and so since then i have of course
been extremely attentive to what is
going on there especially because
you know a lot of people think that
these types of omens of course are silly
they're ridiculous
but i would be more i would be less
skeptical if i were you after spending
many many years listening to my videos
for some of you
i hope that you would understand that
symbolism happens
and that the fact that this happened and
the fact that it follows an almost
mythical structure you know that this
event has a mythical structure and that
not only does it have a mythical
structure but that has shown itself
to be true that is that the peace in
ukraine is not
there and it's not happening and not
only that but there is something there
is a sense
that
this event these things that are
happening in ukraine you know and
everybody kind of has this feeling that
there's something of course bigger going
on
and that there's an unraveling happening
an unraveling
of
a certain narrative an unraveling of
you know let's say
american supremacy we're not sure
exactly what it is but there definitely
is a feeling like something is breaking
down
and that the consequences of what is
happening
are not going to be short-term
consequences and the fact that that
president
putin went out and did such a daring act
of invasion
is going to
is not going to play out well it's not
going to play out well i don't know how
what's going to happen i don't know how
it's going to play out but that it seems
like we are
ramping up
from you know
we are ramping up from the covid moment
into
into war and you
know this happened 100 years ago folks i
just want i hope you understand that
these patterns they they play themselves
back over and over there's a
relationship between
epidemics and war and there's relation
there's all these strange
relationships of how these things kind
of play into each other and how they
move from one space to the next and so
the conflict and you can see it
everybody knows if you pay attention to
attention
how the war on attention and the war of
attention
moved radically from kobe to russia
within the space of a week
within the space of of one week covid is
almost almost doesn't exist and now all
of a sudden
all our attention is moved from a war on
a virus to now an actual war that is
happening and people's rhetoric is
inflamed and people's attitudes are
frightening to say the least
um and you know
i guess if if you asked me if i knew
this was coming i knew this was coming i
didn't i didn't know how it was going to
play out but i knew that
that the pattern of what happened a
century ago was never
solved the problems that were brought up
the issues that kind of came about when
solved and they're playing out again and
we can see how the political aspect of
this conflict is much bigger than just a
conflict between russia and ukraine and
has an entire
the positioning that people are taking
has a weird globalist
sense to it whereas
it's difficult to
it's difficult to oppose what russia is
doing
without falling into something else
something which is frightening as well
in terms of you know
what is going on you know i've talked
about
i've talked about how the 666 symbolism
is growing and how the pattern of
systems of control is becoming more and
more apparent systems of control out of
which you cannot escape and now these
systems of control are showing
themselves just
naked just nakedly showing themselves
out in public
and
the covid situation has made that more
and more visible and now the russia's
the russian
attack has made it even more visible to
see
what is going to play out in terms of
this
this system of control and this kind of
world system
of control
we saw here in canada with the the
trucker protest how
the
the use of
you know blocking people's bank accounts
of closing down their access to funds
was done without flinching that is if
this is something which is completely
normal to do
and now we're seeing the same thing
happening that is the sanctions that are
that are brought upon russia
the idea of shutting down services of of
closing off accesses uh to banks
um you know google pay apple pay
stopping just not working anymore in
russia all of a sudden people come you
know normal people coming to the store
and trying to pay with their phones and
then they just can't they just can't pay
it's not accessible to them and we saw
people asking for example elon musk to
turn off all the teslas in russia and so
people don't realize that the the
mechanisms of control
once the power for those mechanisms is
let's say brought about and is rolling
uh it's not just going to be used
against the people you oppose
you can be against what's happening in
russia
and and all of a sudden one
want
you know all these powerful people to
use all these methods in order to clamp
down
on their political enemies and you don't
realize that these types of measures
will then be used even inside countries
and it'll be used against people
uh within and we saw it happened a few
weeks from each other where these
methods were used in the trucker convoy
to shut down people by by closing or
freezing their bank accounts so as we
move towards digital identity as we move
towards digital currency
these methods will become more and more
um
inevitable um and as they become
politicized that is when
things are gonna get uh scary and
they're already politicized we saw it
with kobit and we're gonna see it uh
more and more and so i would have to say
that that's the reason why i haven't
been extremely vocal about what's going
on i've been watching i've been
listening i've been trying to pay
attention to the signs and to the
symbolism which is laying itself out
and
i'm also quite of course i'm also quite
saddened because you know i am
orthodox and
it's hard to understand what's going on
and why this is happening well we can
understand why it's happening in terms
of material causes but there's a there's
a kind of sadness which comes about to
watch um
to watch a a
to watch orthodox christian attack
others and to watch
polarization that's happening within the
church itself
it's very difficult to watch that and to
uh yeah to not be affected
um and so i would say pray for the
people of ukraine uh you know pray also
for
for russia that
that that the russians can understand uh
you know what what they're doing and and
and the the violence that they're
bringing about on other orthodox
christians uh and that god may
that god may forgive us all um as lent
starts it's a very strange time also for
all this to be going on as lent begins
and we are supposed to enter into more
prayer into more
fasting
you know into more
repentance
uh and so hopefully at least for most of
us we can
keep that eye of repentance on ourselves
uh and not just point it out point our
fingers out to the outside but try to uh
to to see our own faults and not to see
the faults of our brothers in this time
of repentance and so everybody
you know i wish you a productive lent
through all this chaos
and uh and we'll talk to you very soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support